Tại vì thật đình của tập cật đình em ngồi thông bà,
giới mạnh của đổi nước này phải đoệch đối chung thành với đàn cộng giản.
Và thế bố sẽ tiếp tục đầy mạnh trên sức trong thăm lúc trong lực lượng trang,
ông khẳng lịch không có lời ở nấu cho thăm lúc và cuộc đúng trình này
phải được tiến hành lâu dài.
Theo hẳng thông cận tân hoa giá, phát biểu lực lâu dài trong mối cảnh trụ quốc
đang tổ chất kỳ họp thường miền của các cơ quan là pháp và chính chi hàng đầu.
Đây là sự kiện nơi các lạnh đạo nước này,
có bố các định hổng trí sách lớn cho nằm hành hình trong hành hành sấu.
Tại ki học chỉ phụ trụ quốc đã một tiêu tăng trưởng người đề bây năng này
ở mức bố phẩy nằm đến nằm phánh chăm.
Được xem là mức thấp nhất trong khoảng bà mâm lắm năm,
phà nãy nhìn thấy tất cả tình tây trong vàng ngoài nước,
lối với nền bình tầy lần thứ 2 thế giới.
Sông xong với các mục tiêu kình tầy thận trong,
bất kênh tục thông vào tăng chi tự quốc phòng thêm khoảng bẩy phần chăm cho nằm hành hành hình
hành hành hành sấu.
Lần thái này, nhằm tiếp tục hiện đại hóa quân đội và nâng cao năng lực trên đấu quốc
quân dải phòng nhân dật chủ quốc.
Những tình bố quân tập được đưa ra trong bù cạnh chính giết chống tham đứng cho quân đội
và đăng được lấy mạnh.
Một số quan trí tốt cao của nơi,
vắng mắt đại các sự kẹt chính trị quân trong,
làm giấy lên nhận đình dàng,
chính giết thành lọc nộ lộ trong được đường vi tràng chủ quốc và tiếp tục được trên thái.